[PULSATING MUSIC PLAYING]
[WHOOSH]
STEVE BAZYL: Hi, everyone.
I'm Steve Bazyl.
Thanks for watching today.
For today, I want to talk about
something that's been
personally bothering me
with some of the app
integrations I've seen.
And this is apps that are
implementing their own file
pickers on top of
the Drive API.
And first, what do I mean
by a file picker?
This is really something
that most of you
should be familiar with.
It's an interface for selecting
files from a file
system, very much like what you
would see if you were to,
say, do a native file upload
from your file system.
People are building similar
interfaces for selecting files
from cloud services like Drive
as well as other services like
Dropbox, Evernote, and so on.
And the overwhelming reason for
why I've heard of people
wanting to do this really comes
down to UX consistency.
They basically want the
interface to feel like it's
part of the way their
app looks and feels.
And I'm going to go into that
just a little bit more.
The other two reasons
that this comes up--
and these are a little bit
more technical reasons--
one is having to do with missing
features with some of
the alternative solutions or for
mobile applications where
a native file picker for
that cloud service
may or may not exist.
And I'll show you a couple
screenshots.
We can switch over to
my screen here.
I just want you to show
two quick ones.
These are from apps that I've
seen, just to give you a sense
of what people are building.
I'm not going to say which
apps these are.
But some of you may have seen
these interfaces before.
But here's one for picking from
Drive and another one
here which very much shows what
some of these issues are.
So there's four reasons why the
approaches that some of
these developers have taken
are problematic.
Number one is pretty
straightforward.
It has to do with security.
Since we launched the Drive API
about a year ago, we have
been pushing this notion of
file-based permissions.
So we have this drive.file
scope, which limits your
application's access to only
those files that the user
chooses to share with
your application.
For this to work, though, it
requires that we know which
files the user chooses
to share.
And that's only possible
if they do some
action via our UI.
And that happens automatically
when they open a file
from the Drive UI.
It also works if you use our
pre-built Picker Widget.
And I'll show you some demos of
that in just a few minutes.
And we think this is actually
very important.
In order to implement your own
file picker, you need elevated
permissions.
At a minimum, you would
need read-only
access to the file metadata.
If you actually need to read the
contents of those files,
you would also need, at
a minimum, just full
read access to Drive.
If you were to save files back,
then you would need
write access as well.
But the point is that you need
a lot of permissions in order
to actually build something
like this interface.
And the more permissions you
have, the more access you have
to drive, the more the
user is exposed.
We certainly trust that most
developers out there take
security seriously.
But every time there's an
application that has elevated
access, that is one additional
point of risk.
So we strongly encourage
applications not to ask for
more permissions
than they need.
And one of the best ways to do
that is to use pre-built
picker widgets like ours in
order to minimize the level of
access that you have.
The second reason why these
tend to be problematic--
and you can actually see here in
this particular screen shot
that I showed--
is a lot of developers
don't design and
test with large corpora.
Most of the time, people will
set up a test account.
And they'll put in a couple
dozen files and folders and
make sure that, yeah, they can
navigate and show files and
show folders and navigate
the hierarchy.
But then you get somebody who
is a Google Apps user--
maybe they're a part of a large
organization, or they're
really heavy Drive users, like
those of us here at Google--
and these interfaces
fall over.
Personally, for example, just
for my google.com account, I
certainly have thousands or
even tens of thousands of
files and folders, plus all the
files that are shared with
me, which is just an incredibly
large number of files.
And there's been a few
applications that I've tested
out in the past few weeks where
I would go and try to
upload a file, and their picker
interface would time out.
It would give me an error.
In this particular case, they
didn't anticipate somebody
having more than 100 folders in
their top-level directory.
So you really have to plan ahead
for not just simple test
users or casual users but really
the business users, the
people who are the power users
and heavily use Drive and have
thousands, tens of thousands,
even hundreds of thousands of
files within their database.
The other area where the size
of the corpus matters is on
the response time for queries.
For example, our google.com
corpus is so large that some
of the queries, just the default
page size that we use
for the Drive API
is too large.
And just in my own testing, in
order to reliably get results
back quickly from the Drive API
for a files.list call, I
really had to scale the page
size down to about 50.
And default is somewhere
around 1,000 or so.
And so you can see how once
you're dealing with these
larger sets of files, especially
if you have to
really restrict yourself down
to about 50 files per call,
that's a much more effective
pattern for me.
And so it's frustrating to go
to an application where the
file that I want to upload is
not something that I created.
It was something that
was shared with me.
And I haven't bothered to take
the time to organize it into
my own folder structure.
And then I'm presented with an
interface that makes it very
difficult for me to
get that content.
And again, implementing
alternatives, such as Search,
or at least something
complementary to a file
picker, such as Search,
is really important.
And lastly, I do want to talk
to this issue of UX
consistency.
So again, the main reason why
people have chosen to do their
own pickers has really been
because they want this
interface to look like the rest
of their application.
And this is really a
debatable point.
And I think there's a strong
argument to be made that for
Drive users, it's equally as
consistent to give them an
interface that is the same as
what they normally see on a
day-to-day basis with Drive.
And the file picker that we give
to you as a third-party
developer is actually the same
picker that we use within our
own properties.
So it appears within Google
Drive, within the editors.
It appears in some of the other
properties such as Google+.
So it's for Google users, people
who are going to be
using this particular
functionality.
It's an interface that they're
already comfortable using.
And so you have to weigh that
level of consistency and
comfort against wanting to have
that balance with your
own application.
So that said, what are the
preferred approaches?
And really the simplest one,
if you're building a web
application, is to use
our Picker Widget.
I'm going to switch over to just
a quick little demo here,
just to share some of
the customizations
that you can do.
But this is our Picker
Widget, assuming--
OK, here we go.
It's going to load.
I'm not doing this on my
corporate account.
So this is actually a fairly
small purpose.
But trust me when I say that
this actually works equally as
fast, actually even faster,
on my google.com account.
It's pretty straightforward.
You can actually do some
customizations here.
Say I want to separate out my
files versus things that are
shared with me and
allow upload.
We actually have a nice
little drag-and-drop.
Or we can do upload from our
native file system that
actually uploads into Drive and
then shares that file out
to your application.
There's some really cool stuff
you can do with the views.
So I'm actually going here.
Right now you can see we
have these controls.
I can toggle over here and get
a nice thumbnail view.
Some of these actually don't
have thumbnails.
But you can scroll down, and
we start to see those
thumbnails load.
It's a little slower than
it should be today.
But we can also pin that
view into something.
So if you just want to force it
into a thumbnail view, we
can do that as well.
You could also do things like
filter by MIME type, go back
to List, and then anything
that's not that MIME type will
actually get filtered out.
Of course, you can always
navigate into folders.
And that is good, really
straightforward.
The cool thing with the Picker,
though, is it's not
limited to just Google Drive.
So if you want to allow people
to pick from YouTube, from
Google Image Search, there's
a whole bunch of other
properties that it actually
integrates into YouTube.
Really powerful.
And you can go over to
developers.google.com/picker
to learn more about that
and how it works.
But it's a really powerful
interface.
So that would be the
preferred approach.
There are a couple limitations,
of course.
The two are currently
you cannot select
folders as the target.
So you can pick files
from Drive.
But there are cases where
developers may
need to select a folder.
And so you can think of this
as cases of, say, selecting
the target for dropping files.
So you're doing online faxing or
e-signatures, and you want
the equivalent of a Dropbox
folder so you can dump in
incoming files.
If you're a scanner, where
to save things
that they've scanned.
And also as a location where
you might want to
be consuming files.
So we see this with applications
like IFT and a
few others that do these file
automations, and they just
watch a folder for changes.
So there are cases where you're
not interested in one
particular file, but you just
want to find a destination
that you can then do something
interesting with.
In that case, the Picker
just doesn't work.
That's more of a bug on our end
and something that we hope
to fix fairly soon.
But the other case, which is
a little bit harder to deal
with, is mobile.
And right now the Picker
is web-only.
We don't have a native picker
for any of the mobile
platforms right now.
And unfortunately, the Web
Picker doesn't really respond
well to being viewed
on a mobile device.
It's not quite designed
to be responsive.
And so, developers, if you're
building a mobile application
and you do need to select files
or folders for Drive,
you are pretty much left
with building your own.
There are some alternatives
to our Picker.
One that I think is kind of
cool is Filepicker.io.
This is a really interesting
developer product.
They basically built a layer
on top of Drive and all the
other cloud storage
providers--
Dropbox, Box, SkyDrive,
Evernote, you name it--
and they give you a set of
pre-built components.
And you can see here all their
different services.
And I can click in Drive and
just navigate through
everything just as well.
And they have mobile
pickers as well.
They do have some of the same
restrictions in terms of I'm
not entirely sure if they
support folder selection.
There are some issues if you are
trying to do an app that
supports both open from Drive as
well as using their picker.
Within their app, they do mask
the underlying file IDs.
This is done for security
reasons.
That does make it a little bit
difficult to implement both
use cases--
open from Drive and then pick a
file from within your app--
because you end up having to do
our Drive API for that one
use case and then their API
for a separate use case.
If your application doesn't
need to be launched from
within the Drive UI,
Filepicker.io is actually a
really nice solution.
And it has the benefit that it
gets you basically support for
all of the cloud-storage
solutions with one
integration.
But again, it doesn't solve
every use case.
But it is something that I
would certainly encourage
people to look for if that is
the use case that they're
trying to implement.
Another option--
and this speaks more towards
the folder case--
which is if you're trying to set
a destination for where to
put files, rather than
giving users a
choice, just pick a default.
And you actually see this a
lot with applications like
HelloFax and HelloSign, a few
others that are just creating
destination folders
for their content.
They don't even present
a choice to the users.
And the nice thing is since
Drive is based off of opaque
IDs, so we have unique
identifier for files, it
doesn't matter if the user then
goes and renames that
folder or moves it, reorganizes
it, once you
create that folder and you have
that ID, the user can do
whatever they want to it.
And you'll still be able to do
writes to that folder no
matter where it goes,
if they share it,
they rename it, whatever.
So the easiest thing
is just don't even
bother with a picker.
Just create what you need,
and you're good to go.
So for those cases where you
don't really have a choice--
you're building a mobile
application, you need to be
able to let users select from
existing folders, and you
can't create a new one just
for your application--
just a few things to watch out
for based on some of the
earlier problems.
One is certainly try to minimize
the level of access
that you need.
If you are only reading
the content--
Actually, better yet, we'll
start with the most
restrictive, which is if
you just need to pick a
destination folder, you can
actually pick a fairly narrow
scope to build your picker.
So what you would do is you can
combine drive.file with
drive.readonly.metadata.
What that would do is you would
have full read/write
access to the files
you create.
But for the purposes of the
picker, you would only have
read access to the file
metadata, which would be
enough for you to show
the navigation
structure for those folders.
But you would not be able
to read the contents.
You would not be able to write
to any of those files.
And that would be a pretty
reasonable way to narrow down
the permissions for that case.
If you do actually need to read
the file that you just
selected, then instead of doing
drive.readonly.metada,
you would use drive.readonly,
which would then let you read
that content.
If you actually need to read
and write, then you have to
use the full Drive scope.
The other thing is if you are
building your own picker
interface, consider adding
a search option.
This is really important for
users that are parts of large
organizations.
They have far, far, far more
files than your typical user.
Many of those are files that are
shared from coworkers and
may not be organized in a way
that a file-oriented or
folder-oriented navigation
structure is
really great for them.
Adding a search option
is really easy.
Just add a text field that
API supports Search.
It's pretty easy to do that
as an alternative.
It's probably easier to do
Search than it is to actually
build a file picker.
And it's just way more useful
for users to have that.
And actually, I ran into
a case recently--
not one that I showed-- an
application that had their own
Drive file picker, but they
also had some YouTube
integration.
And the way they required users
to say which YouTube
video they wanted to attach was
they had to go to YouTube,
find the video, extract the
video ID from the URL, and
then copy that back
into their field.
And it's just horribly, horribly
painful for users to
do that when the YouTube API
has a search capability.
They could have just as well
have embedded YouTube Search
right in there and then
extracted out the relevant
information themselves.
So really, please don't
underappreciate the power that
Search has for these
use cases.
And lastly, is just to make
sure that you test with a
large corpus.
You don't have to have
gigabytes of data.
The actual file size is
somewhat irrelevant.
But when you do create your test
accounts, make sure that
you are creating a significant
number of folders at the root
level, as nested folders, and
also to make sure that there
are regular files in there as
well, just so that the number
of files that you need to fetch
is some significant
multiple of the page size.
So like, set your
page size to 50.
And then make sure you have
1,000 or so folders in there.
That way, you can see how your
picker is responding when you
have to make 5 or 6 or 10
requests in order to populate
the results.
And I think once you do that,
you're going to start to find
out where these seams are,
figure out ways to
incrementally show those
results, and just make that
interface much, much more
responsive for users that are
heavy Drive users or parts of
large organizations that have
these tens or hundreds
of thousands, or even
millions, of files.
If we're dealing with RESTful
APIs, I would certainly
strongly encourage everyone
to use the Picker API.
So that's it for today.
Again, I hope this was useful
and motivates people to do the
right thing for their users.
We'll be back next week.
I'm not sure if we
have a topic yet.
But we'll let everyone know
as soon as we can.
Thanks.
[WHOOSH]
[PULSATING MUSIC PLAYING]